JUMPER.
I WOULD JUMP WITH HIM IN A DUNK
CONTEST.
>> ALL RIGHT.
COLE ANTHONY, LET'S SEE WHO
BRINGS A LITTLE BIT OF THE
ENTERTAINMENT VALUE.
>> BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO BE
CREATIVE NOWADAYS, RIGHT?
YOU JUST CAN'T COME OUT AND HAVE
HARD DUNK.
>> WHO IS HE CALLING OUT HERE?
YOU GOT TO TELL A STORY.
POP'S OUT ON THE FLOOR.
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
BRING DAD OUT.
GET HIM OUT OF RETIREMENT.
>> OH!
>> THERE HE IS.
>> HEY, HEY, HEY!
LOOK AT POP.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> POPS IS LOOKING AT HIM LIKE,
SEE, YOU SEE COLE IS FROM NEW
YORK CITY.
>> GOT HIS DAD'S JERSEY ON.
HE IS GOING TO DUNK IN TEN.
THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
HIS POP DON'T STOP.
>> YOU GO TO THAT CORNER AND LET
ME PUSH HIM OFF REALLY QUICK AND
GRAB THE BASKETBALLS.
THAT WOULD BE MORE LIKE IT FOR
GREG ANTHONY.
>> WHEN YOU FROM NEW YORK
CITY --
>> NOW YOU GOT IT RIGHT.
>> REGGIE IS STILL MAD ABOUT
THAT.
D-WADE GOT IT.
>> REGGIE IS STILL HOT ABOUT
THAT.
>> LISTEN, MAN, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT.
HE DON'T HAVE NO SCUFFS ON HIS
TIPS.
THAT'S LIKE A McLAREN.
WHEN YOU HAVE TIPS BACK IN NEW
YORK, THAT'S WHAT HE IS --
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO WE KNOW HE CAN PROBABLY DUNK
THE BASKETBALL.
BUT IT'S GOT TO BE --
>> SOMEONE IN THE REGULAR --
>> I THINK HE IS GOING TO --
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
WE PLAYED IN THE PARK.
WE USED TO PLAY IN OUR --
>> JALEN GREEN, HIS SOCKS.
>> INDEED.
>> THAT MEANS SOMETHING, YOU
DUNKING IN YOUR SOCKS.
>> TAKE YOUR TIME, YOUNG MAN.
WE GOT ALL NIGHT.
>> 43-INCH VERTICAL.
WHAT DOES THAT TRANSLATE TO?
BRAND NEW OUT OF THE BOX.
>> THAT'S ANOTHER NUMBER.
>> NO, OBI TOPPIN IS LIKE, HEY,
LISTEN --
>> STOP HATING.
STOP HATING.
>> WHERE THE CLOCK AT?
>> WHERE IS THE SCLOK?
>> STOP HATING.
>> HE IS DRESSED AND HE GOT THE
NEW YORK JERSEY ON.
>> HE IS READY.
>> MY MAN IS DUNKING IN TTIMS.
THIS IS A NEW YORK CITY THING.
>> Y'ALL EXCITED.
ALL HE NEED IS A GOLD CHAIN AND
A KANGO.
>> I FEEL LIKE I WANT GREG IT
TURN AROUND.
>> GRAB THE CHAINS OFF THE
SIDELINES.
>> TAKE YOUR TIME.
>> THEY SHOULD KNOW THIS FATHER.
THIS IS FATHER/SON.
THEY SHOULD HAVE THIS
CHOREOGRAPHED.
>> TAKE IT IN.
SHOULDERS BACK.
HE MAY CATCH IT.
>> YEAH.
AND HE IS TALKING TO THE JUDGES
RIGHT NOW.
HE GOT US ANTICIPATING WHAT HE
IS ABOUT TO DO.
>> HE BETTER MAKE THE FIRST ONE.
>> YES, INDEED.
COME ON, GET UP, GET UP, GET UP.
>> OKAY.
GIVES YOU A LITTLE HINT.
>> THAT WAS A FAKE-OUT.
HE DIDN'T EVEN TRY TO DUNK THAT.
THAT WAS A FANGOUT.
THAT WAS A FAKE-OUT.
>> IT MAY BE A GRAB AND A
ONE-HAND DUNK.
>> I THINK HE IS GOING TO SAKE
HIS SIMS OFF, PUT HIS REGULAR
SHOES ON.
>> YOU'RE GOOD.
>> WE GOT AN EXPLANATION.
>> NO, YOU'RE GOOD.
>> HEY, WE WILL HE BE HERE
TOMORROW FOR THE ALL-STAR GAME
TRYING TO DO THIS DUNK.
>> HEY, LET'S GO, LET'S GO.
GIANNIS HAS HIS PHONE OUT OVER
THERE.
OKAY.
THAT DOESN'T COUNT.
LET'S GO, LET'S GO.
HE IS LOSING HIM.
HE IS LOSING HIM RIGHT NOW.
>> GOT TO PUT HIS SNEAKS BACK
ON.
>> YEAH, PUT YOUR SNEAKS BACK
YOU ARE LOSING HIM.
HE HAS DUNKED IN TIMS BEFORE.
HERE IT IS.
>> IT WAS THE ANGLE.
>> YEAH.
>> THAT WASN'T BAD.
THAT'S LIKE AN EIGHT TO WARMUP.
GOT THE CROWD ON HIS SIDE.
HE DID IT THE SECOND TIME, HE
WOULD HAVE HAD EVERYBODY.
BUT HE GOT HALF OF US.
>> WE STILL NEVER SEEN THAT
BEFORE.
SO I LIKE IT.
>> I HAVE SEEN IT BEFORE IN THE
PARK.
PRACTICE IN THE PARK.
DUDES DUNKING LIKE THAT.
>> DID YOU USED TO DO IT?
HAVE YOU EVER DONE THIS DUNK IN
THE PARK?
>> I HAVE DUNKED WITH TIMS ON.
NOT LIKE THAT.
>> OKAY.
>> I DUNKED WITH TIMS ON.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LISTEN, ALL RIGHT.
>> I WOULD HAVE BEEN MORE
IMPRESSED IF HE DUNKED ON THE
FIRST --
>> THE AMIGOS IS LIKE, WHAT'S
THAT?
HE IS LIKE, THAT'S HOT!
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> DEPENDS ON THE WAY YOU RAP,
WHERE YOU ARE BALLING.
>> THE CROWD IN CLEVELAND, THEY
SITTING THERE LIKE, WHAT'S GOING
ON?
>> SCORES ARE IN FROM OUR
JUDGES.
40 HERE.
DOMINIQUE WILKINS, ISAIAH
THOMAS, DR. J, DAVID ROBINSON.
AND THIS ONE GOES FOR 40.
>> HOW IS THAT?
YOU WANT TO START OUT WITH A
EIGHT.
>> THAT'S SOLID.
SOLID.
>> I DON'T KNOW, GUYS.
>> I FEEL LIKE JALEN GREEN IS
GOING TO BRING US MORE THAN
EIGHT.
>> YO, HE IS PLAYING CATCH-U